ملف الطاقه العالميه اعلنت دول مجموعه
السبعه واستراليا توصل الى اتفاق مبدئيا
لتطبيق حد اقصى لسعر النفط الروسي
المنقولي بحرا عند 60 دولارا للبرميل مع
اليه تعديل لابقاء السعر ادنى من مستوى
السوق في حال انخفاض الاسعار من المرجح ان
يدخل هذا السعر حيزه تنفيذ في غضون ايام
وقالت مجموعه السبع من القرار يهدف الى
حرمان موسكو من وسائل تمويل حربها على
اوكرانيا
من جهتها رحبت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه
جانيت يلن باعلان مجموعه الدول سبعه
والاتحاد الاوروبي واستراليا عن سقف لسعر
النفط الروسي المنقولي بحرا قناتنا
القراره سيساعد في تقييد مصدر دخل الرئيس
الروسي لتمويل حربه في اوكرانيه مع الحفاظ
على استقرار امدادات الطاقه عالميه ذكرت
الوزيره في بيان ان تحديد سقف للاسعار
مصمم للمساعده في حمايه المستهلكين
والشركات ان اضطرابات الامدادات العالميه
وفي المقابل قالت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ان
الاقتصاد الروسيه سيدامر بتحديد سقف
لاسعار النفط اما السفاره الروسيه في
الولايات المتحده فاكدت ان روسيا ليس
لديها شك في ان نفضها سيظل مطلوبا في
الاسواق العالميه حتى بعد تطبيق قرار الحد
الاقصى للاسعار
وانا بعد سفاره الروسيه من زياده واسعه
امطار في عدم اليقين وارتفاع تكاليف
المستهلكيه المواد الخام واشارت الى ان
جميع الدول اضحك غير محصله ضد فرض سقف على
منتجاتها تصديريه لاسباب سياسيه حسب
تعبيرها كمشدد نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسيه
الكسندر نوفاك على ان روسيا ستعمل فقط
بشروط السوق ولن تابع نفطها للدول التي
ستضع سقفا للاسعار في السياق ذاته قال
رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه بمجلس الدمى
الروسي ان الاتحاد الاوروبيه عبر عبر
قراره تحديدا سقف لسعر النفط الروسيه
المنقول بحرا سيتسبب لنفسه في ازمه في
مجال الطاقه اعتبر ان القرار يصب في مصلحه
الولايات المتحده التي ستزداده ثراءا حسب
ما قال